yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
I've just seen x-men apocalypse and can
confirm as a single post-credit scene
right at the very end of the movies
credits in this video I'm going to break
down and explain what's in the scene and
what it means for future x-men movies so
there will be spoilers ahead if you want
to avoid any spoilers click here for my
spoiler free review or comeback after
you've seen the movie the post credits
scene begins was a small group of men in
black suits walking through the
corridors of the Weapon X facility while
a clean up operation is in progress
blood and bodies are being cleared from
the floor and bullets are also being
vacuumed up one of the suited man who
wears glasses also carries a briefcase
and he uses a keycard to enter one of
the labs obviously x-rays of a body and
skulls reminiscent of the x-rays from
the alkali Lake facility that first
appeared in the second x-men movie in
the lab the suited man takes a vial of
dark red liquid labeled Weapon X which
is likely a sample of Wolverines blood
and he puts it in his briefcase which
has at least three other vials in it
each with different colored liquids the
colors and the other vials are green
yellow and there's another with an
almost clear liquid as the man closes
the briefcase we see a large chrome
label with the words ethics Corp the
name Essex is a huge keys for the comic
book villain mr. sinister also known as
dr. Nathaniel Essex in the comics
Nathaniel Essex is a Darwinist
geneticist obsessed with developing a
superior species
he shares apocalypse his outlook that
only the strongest should survive and he
actually works with him after apocalypse
turns him into mr. sinister which is the
last word his wife said to him on her
deathbed in the comics sinister has a
history of collecting genetic material
for mutants and in the Weapon X comics
he surreptitiously collected a vial of
blood from Marvel's first mutant Namur
when he was injured by the Nazis during
World War two sinister then used nemours
blood for his experiments creating a
clone of namur that he tried out against
Captain America so if that is indeed
Wolverines blood in the vial and x-men
apocalypse that could be a big hint that
we may see the female Wolverine clone
x-23 appear in wolverine 3 producer
Simon Kinberg has already pitched a
female Wolverine character to Fox and
Hugh Jackman has said that the next
Wolverine solo movie will be is last
cloning x-23 from Wolverines genetic
material could be an interesting way to
introduce an alternative version of one
of Fox's most popular mutants to date by
the way Deadpool director Tim Miller has
said he'd love to see Deadpool fight
x-23 and what about there's other vials
in the briefcase
well Wolverine 3 casting has confirmed
were getting Richard E grant as a
villainous mad scientist-type
so he could be the movie version of dr.
Abraham Cornelius a Weapon X scientist
working on replicating Wolverine and
other mutants powers in the comics
if mr. sinister has been able to collect
genetic material from any of the other
x-men who were trapped at Strykers
Weapon X building it's always possible
we'll see clones of them in future films
too and if he has any of Jean Grey's
genes he could create her clone Madeline
Pryor which he creates in the comics
cable who's a child of Cyclops and
Madeline Pryor is confirmed as appearing
in Deadpool 2 so he could see sinister
involved in cables origin story mr.
sinister is a major villain in the x-men
comics and Simon Kinberg that said that
he could show up in the gambit movie as
well as the x-men films in the comics
Remy LeBeau has a history of working
with dr. Essex as an agent of his so
assuming the gambit movie does get made
it looks likely mr. sinister will pop up
there too I think mr. sinister could
also be used to build up a more unified
x-men movie universe in a similar way to
how Marvel Studios is used son asked to
tie together it's different superheroes
and villains and build them towards
infinity war so guys what do you think
about the post-credits tease for mr.
sinister and who would you like to see
cast as a villain Bryan Cranston already
said that he'd really like to play mr.
sinister at New York Comic Con last year
so do you think he'd be a good choice
just to let you know coming up I'll have
a cool giveaway for two sets of official
Fox x-men apocalypse merchandise on my
upcoming apocalypse videos so make sure
you subscribe for my full movie Easter
Egg Guide and more breakdown to the
movie coming shortly and to check out
more of those videos click right for my
full x-men apocalypse playlist with my
movie review Easter Egg Guide and
breakdowns and click left for my Captain
America Civil War post credits breakdown
an easter egg videos if you enjoyed this
don't forget to subscribe like and share
thanks for watching and see you next
time you'd be going movie lovers